hi there this is Samuel and I'm very
excited that you're watching this video
and I'm equally glad that we were able
to provide you a second part in AWS
interview questions if you haven't
watched the first part yet
please go back and watch the first part
we have a lot of interesting questions
there which will better prepare you for
the interview all right let's get
started so in an environment where there
is a lot of automation infrastructure
automation you'll be posted with this
question how can you add an existing
instance to a new auto scaling group now
this is when you are taking an instance
away from the auto scaling group to
troubleshoot to fix a problem you know
to look at logs or if you have suspended
the auto scaling you know you might need
to riad that instance to the auto
scaling group only then it's gonna take
part in it right only then the auto
scaling is gonna count it has part of it
it's not a straight procedure you know
when you remove them you know it doesn't
get automatically Lee added I've had
worked with some clients so when their
developers were managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance back to the auto scaling group
you know irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the auto scaling group and whatever they
fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
we're not you know getting encountered
in in the auto scaling group so like I
said it's not a straight you know a
click button procedure there are ways
we'll have to do it so how can you add
an existing instance to the auto scaling
group there are a few steps that we need
to follow so the first one would be to
under the ec2 instance console right
under the instance under actions in
specific you know there's an option
called attach to auto scaling group
right if you have multiple auto scaling
groups in your account or in the region
that you're working in then you're going
to be posted with the different auto
scaling groups that you have in your
account let's say you have five or a
scaling groups or five different
application you know you're gonna be are
posted with five different auto scaling
groups and then you would
elect the auto-scaling the appropriate
auto scaling group and attach the
instance to that particular auto scaling
group while adding to the auto scaling
group if you want to change the instance
type you know that's possible as well
sometimes when you want to add the
instance back to the auto scaling group
there would be requirement that you
change the instance type to a better one
to a better family to the better
instance type you could do that at that
time and after that you are or you have
completely added the instance back to
the auto scaling group so it's actually
an the seven step a process adding an
instance back to the auto scaling group
in an environment where they dealing
with migrating the instance or migrating
an application or migrating an instance
migrating and VM into the cloud
you know if the project that you're
gonna work with deals with a lot of
migrations you could be posted this
question what are the factors you will
consider while migrating to Amazon Web
Services the first one is cost is it
worth moving the instance to the cloud
given the additional bills and wizzle's
features available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes no cost of the
infrastructure and the ability to match
the demand and supply transparency is
this application and high demand you
know is it gonna be a big loss if the
application becomes unavailable for some
time
so there are few things that needs to be
considered before we move the
application to the cloud and then if the
application does the application needs
to be provisioned immediately is there
an urge is there an urge to provision
the application immediately that's
something that needs to be considered if
the application requires to go online if
the application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on-premises
procuring buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
and I'm buying the software's buying the
license relate
- it's gonna take time at least like two
weeks or so before you can bring up and
server and launch an application in it
right so the application cannot wait you
know waiting means you know workforce
productivity loss is it so we would want
to immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
there is the urge in making the
application go online as soon as
possible then that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if the the software or if
the product that you're launching it
requires hardware
it requires an updated or hardware all
the time that's not going to be possible
in on-premises
we try to deal with legacy
infrastructure all the time in
on-premises but in the cloud they're
constantly upgrading their hardware's
only then they can keep themselves up
going in the market so they're
constantly the cloud providers are
constantly updating their hardware's and
if you want to be benefited of your
application wants to be benefited by the
constant upgrading of the hardware's
making sure the hardware is as latest as
possible the software version the
licensing is as latest as possible then
that's a candidate to be moved to the
cloud and if the application does not
want to go through any risk if the
application is very sensitive to
failures if the application is very much
tied to the Sevigny of the company and
you don't want to take a chance in you
know seeing the application fail and you
know seeing the revenue drop then that's
a candidate for moving to the cloud and
business agility you know moving to the
cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's Amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails Amazon makes sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make yourself aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between Amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
product that you're launching then it
needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is RTO and RPO in AWS they are
essentially disaster recovery terms when
you're planning for disaster recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about RTO and
RPO now what's the RTO what's the RPO in
your environment or how to define RTO
how do you define RPO are some general
questions that get asked a tio is a
recovery time objective RTO stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or
for the recovery to finish when an
disaster strikes
so RTO is in the future right how much
time is it gonna take to fix and bring
everything to normal so that's Artyom on
the other hand RP o is recovery point
objective which is the maximum amount of
data loss your company is willing to
accept as measured in time RP o always
refers to the backups the number of
backups the the frequency of the backups
right because when an outage happens you
can always go back to the latest backup
right and if the latest backup was
before 12 hours you have lost the
in-between twelve hours of data data
storage right so RP o is the acceptable
amount if the company wants less RP o
our view is 1r then you should be
planning on taking backups everyone up
if RP o is 12 hours then you should be
planning on taking backups every 12
hours so that's how RP o and RTO you
know helps disaster recovery the fourth
question you could get asked is if you
would like to transfer a huge amount of
data which is the best option among a
snowball snowball edge and snowmobile
again this is a question that get our if
the company is dealing with lot of data
transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with migrating data
into the cloud I'm talking about a huge
amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the parabot sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as of now AWS snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified AWS region on the other hand a
w snowball edge adds additional
computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball Edge has a compute function
attached to it a snowmobile on the other
hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up 200 petabytes that's like a hundred
thousand terabytes so depending on the
size of data that we want to transfer
from our data center to the cloud we can
hire we can rent any of these three
services let's talk about some cloud
formation questions this is a classic
question how is AWS cloud formation
different from AWS elastic beanstalk
you know from the surface they both look
like the same you know you don't go
through the console provisioning
resources you don't you know you don't
go through CLI and provision resources
both of them provision resources through
click button right but underneath they
are actually different services they
support they aid different services so
knowing that is gonna help you
understand this question a lot better
let's talk about the difference between
them and this is what you will be
explaining to the interviewer or the
panelist so the cloud formation the
cloud formation service helps you
describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
Beanstalk provides and simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and the elastic
Beanstalk gives us an small contained
environment in which we can run our
application and the cloud formation
supports the infrastructure needs of
many different types of application like
the enterprise application the legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you
to have in the cloud on the other hand
the elastic Beanstalk it's a combination
offered developer tools there are tools
there helps manage the lifecycle of a
single application so cloud formation in
short is managing the infrastructure as
a whole and elastic beanstalk
in short is managing and running an
application in the cloud and if the
company that you're getting hired is
using cloud formation to manage their
infrastructure user or if they're using
infrastructure or any of the
infrastructure as a core services then
you would definitely face this question
what are the elements of an AWS
CloudFormation template so it has four
or five basic elements right and the
template is in the form of JSON or in
YAML of format so it has parameters it
has outputs it has data it has resources
and then the format or the format
version or the file format version for
the cloud formation template so
parameter is nothing but it actually
lets you to specify the type of easy to
instance that you want the type of RDS
that you want right so ec2 is an
umbrella RDS is an umbrella and
parameters within that easy to end
parameters within that RDS are the
specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the RDS service so
that's what parameters in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
output the name of an s3 bucket that was
created if you want the output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want output
the name of some resources that have
been created instead of looking into the
template instead of you know navigating
through in the console and finding the
name of the resource we can actually
have them out put it in the results
section so you can simply go and look at
all the resources created through the
template in the output section and
that's what output values or output does
in the cloud formation template and then
we have the resources resources are
nothing but what
what are the cloud components or cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource RDS is a resource and s3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and NAT gateway
is a resource VPC is a resource so you
see all these components are the
resources and the resource section and
the cloud formation defines what are the
AWS cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have a version version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is 0
9 0 9 2010 that's the latest version
number you'll be able to find that on
the top of the cloud formation template
and that version number defines the
capabilities of the cloud formation
template so just need to make sure that
it's the latest all the time still
talking about lord formation this is
another classic question what happens
when one of the resources in a stack
cannot be created successfully well if
the resource and a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and terminates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and 11 thru source is now
failing cloud formation will roll back
and delete all the 10 resources that
were created previously and this is very
useful when the cloud formation cannot
you know go forward cloud formation
cannot create additional resources
because we have reached the elastic IP
limits elastic IP limit per region is 5
right and if you have already used 5 IPS
and a cloud formation is trying to buy
three more IPS you know we have hit the
soft limit till we fix that with Amazon
Cloud formation will not be able to in a
launch additional you know resources and
additional IPS so it's gonna cancel and
rollback everything that's true with a
missing easy to ami as well if an ami is
included in the template and
but the EMI is not actually present then
cloud formation is gonna search for the
mi and because it's not present it's
gonna roll back and delete all the
resources that it created so that's what
a cloud formation does it simply rolls
back all the resources that it created I
mean if it sees a failure it would
simply roll back all the resources that
it created and this feature actually
simplifies the system administration and
layered solutions built on top of AWS
CloudFormation so at any point we know
that there are no orphan resources in
the in our environment
you know because something did not work
or because there was an you know cloud
formation executed some there are no
orphan resources in our account at any
point we can be sure that if cloud
formation is launching a resource and if
it's gonna fail and it's going to come
back and delete all the resources it's
created so there are no orphan resources
in our account now let's talk about some
questions in elastic block store again
if the environment deals with lot of
automation you could be thrown this
question how can you automate easy to
back up using EBS it's actually a six
step process to automate the easy to
backup so we'll need to write a script
to automate the below steps using AWS
API and these are the steps that should
be found in the scripts first to get the
list of instances and then and then the
script that we are writing should be
able to connect to a W Singh the API and
list the Amazon EBS volumes that are
attached locally to the instance and
then it needs to list the snapshots of
each volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be invalid right once you have
some 10 latest snapshots any snapshot
that you have taken before that then
becomes invalid because you have
captured the latest and 10 snapshot
coverage is enough for you and then the
fifth point is to create a snapshot of
each volume create a new snapshot of
each volume and then delete the old
snapshot any time a new snapshot gets
created the oldest snapshot the
listening
to go away so we need to include options
we need to include scripts in a script
lines in our script that make sure that
it's deleting the older snapshots which
are older than the retention period that
we are mentioning another question that
you could see in the interview a beat a
written interview beat online interview
or beat and telephonic or face-to-face
interview is what's the difference
between EBS and instant store let's talk
about EBS first EBS is kind of permanent
storage the data in it can be restored
at a later point when we save data in
EBS the data lives even after the
lifetime of the ec2 instance for example
we can stop the instance and the data is
still going to be present in EBS we can
move the EBS from one instance to
another instance and the data is simply
gonna be present there so EBS is kind of
permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand the instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host off the machine EBS is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of the
machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with EBS so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is EBS is permanent
instant store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using EBS and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of EFS like EBS
and if you can take backup how do you
take that back up the answer is yes we
can take EFS tui
first backup solution EFS does not
support snapshot like EBS EFS does not
support snapshot snapshot is not an
option for EFS elastic file system right
we can only take backup from one EFS to
another EFS and this backup solution is
to recover from unintended changes or
deletions of the EFS and this can be
automated but any data that we store an
EFS can be automatically replicated to
another EFS and once this EFS goes down
or gets deleted or data gets deleted or
you know if the whole EFS is for some
reason interrupted or deleted we can
recover the data from we can use the
other EFS and bring the application to
consistency and to achieve this it's not
an one-step a configuration it's a cycle
there are series of steps that's
involved before we can achieve EFS - EFS
backup the first thing is to sign in to
the AWS management console and under EFS
or click on EFS - EFS restore button
from the services list and from there we
can use the region selector in the
console navigation bar to select the
actual region in which we want to work
on and from there
ensure that we have selected the right
template you know some of the templates
would be you know EFS TFS backup
granular backups incremental backups
right so there are some templates the
kind of backups that you want to take
you want to take granular do you want to
take increment backups stuff like that
and then create a name to that a
solution the kind of backup that we have
created and finally review all the
configurations that you have done and
click on save and from that point
onwards the data is going to be copied
and from that point onwards any
additional data that you put is gonna
copy it and replicate it now we have an
EFS - EFS backup this is another classic
question in companies which deals with a
data management there are easy options
to create snapshots but deleting
snapshots is not always and you know
click button or an single step
configuration so you might be facing a
question
like how do you Auto delete old
snapshots and the procedure is like this
now as best practice we will take
snapshots of EBS volume to s3 all
snapshots get stored in s3 we know that
now
and we can use AWS ops Automator to
automatically handle all snapshots the
ops automated service it allows us to
create copy delete EBS snapshots so
there are cloud formation templates
available for AWS optimator and this
Automator template will scan the
environment and it would take snapshots
it would you know copy the snapshot from
one region to another region if you want
you know if you're setting up a dr
environment and not only that based on
the retention period that we create it's
going to delete the snapshots which are
older than the retention period so life
or managing snapshot is made lot easier
because of this ops Automator
CloudFormation template moving into
questions and elastic load balancer this
again could be an a question in the
interview what are the different types
of load balancers in AWS and what's
their use case what's the difference
between them and as of now as we speak
there are three types of load balancers
which are available in AWS the first one
being application a load balancer just
like the name says the application load
balancer works on the application layer
and deals with hesse DB an HTTP request
and it also supports spot based routing
for example simply learn comm slash some
webpage simply learn comm slash another
website so it's gonna direct the part
based on the slash value that you give
in the URLs
that's path based routing so it supports
that and not only that it can support a
port based a colon 8080 colon 8080 1 or
colon 8090 you know based on that port
also it can take a routing decision and
that's what application load balancer
does on the other hand we have Network
load balancer and the network load
balancer makes routing decisions and the
transport level it's faster because it
has very less thing to
gone it works on lower OSI layer it
works on a lower layer so it has very
less information to work with than
compared with application layer so
comparatively it's lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a target group for
the default rule using the flow hash a
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path based or port
based routing it does simple routing and
because of it it's faster and then we
have classic load balancer which is kind
of expiring as we speak
Amazon is discouraging people using
classic load balancer but there are
companies which are still using classic
load balancer they are the ones were the
first one to step in to Amazon when
classic load balancer was the first load
balancer or the only load balancer
available at that point so it supports
HTTP HTTP a TCP SSL protocol and it has
a fixed relationship between a load
balance report and the container port so
initially we only have classic load
balancer and then at after some point
Amazon said instead of having one load
balancer to address all type of traffic
we're gonna have to load balancers
called as the child from the classic to
load balancer and one is gonna
specifically address the application
requirement and one is gonna
specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer a network load
balancer so that's how now we have two
different load balancers talking about
load balance another classic question
could be what are the different uses of
the various load balancer in AWS elastic
a load balancing there are three types
of load balancer we just spoke about it
application load balancer is used if we
need a flexible application management
and the TLS termination and network load
balancer if we require extreme
performance and the load balancing
should happen on based on static IPS for
the application and a classic load
balancer is an old load balancer which
is for people who are still running
their environment from ec2 classic
network now this is an older version of
V PC or this is what was present before
V PC was created ec2 classic network is
what was present before ec2 was created
so there are the three types and they
are the use cases
it let's talk about some of these
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall and AWS we cannot
avoid discussion talking about vas Web
Application Firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use AWS raph in monitoring your
AWS applications graph or web
application firewall protects our web
application from common web exploits and
wofe helps us control which traffic
source your application should be
allowed or a block which traffic from a
certain source you know which source or
which traffic from a certain source
should be allowed or blocked your
application with laughs we can also
create custom rules that blocks common
attack patterns you know if it is a
banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple data
management data storage application it
has main content management application
it has a separate type of attack so
based on the application type we can
identify a pattern and create rules that
would actually block that attack based
on the rule that we create and graph can
be used for three cases you know the
first one is allowed all requests and
then block all requests and count all
requests for a new policy so it's also
an monitoring and management service
which actually counts all the policies
or counts all the requests that matches
a particular policy that we create and
some of the characteristics we can
mention in a WAF or the origin IPS
and the strings that appear in the
request we can allow block based on
origin IP allow block based on strings
that appear in the request we can allow
block or count based on the origin
country length of the request yeah we
can block and count the presence of
malicious scripts in an connection you
know we can count the request headers or
we can allow block a certain request
header and we can count the presence of
malicious SQL code in a connection that
we get and that want to reach our
application still talking about security
what are the different AWS I am
categories we can control using AWS I
we can do the following one is create
and manage IM users and once the user
database gets bigger and bigger we can
create and manage them in groups and an
IM we can use it to manage the security
credentials kind of setting the
complexity of the password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like MFA and you know rotating the
passwords no resetting the password
there are a few things we could do with
I am and finally we can create policies
that actually grants access to aw
services and resources another question
you will see is what are the policies
that you can set for your users password
so some of the policies that we can set
for the user password is at the minimum
length or you know the complexity of the
password by at least having one number
or one special characters in the
password so that's one and then the
requirement of a specific character
types including you know upper case
lower case number and non-alphabetic
characters so it becomes very hard for
somebody else to guess what the password
would be and and try to hack them so we
can set and the length of the password
we can set the complexity in the
password and then we can set an
automatic expiration of the password so
after a certain time the user is forced
to create a new password so the password
is not stale old and easy to guess in
the environment and we can also set
settings like the user should contact
the admin I mean when the password is
about to expire so you know you can get
ahold of how the user is setting their
password is it having good complexity in
it is it meeting company standards or
there are a few things that we can
control and set for the users when the
users are setting or recreating the
password another question that could be
posted in an interview so to understand
your understanding of iam is what's the
difference between an I am role and then
I am user let's talk about I am user
let's start small and then go big or
let's start simple and then talk about
the complex one the I am user has
a permanent long-term credential and
it's used to interact directly with AWS
services and on the other hand I am role
is an I am entity that defines a set of
permissions for making AWS service
requests so I am user is an permanent
credential and role are temporary
credentials and I am user has full
access to all aw I am functionalities
and with role trusted entity such as I
am users application or aw services
assume at the role so when and I am user
is given and a permission you know it
sticks within the I am user but with
roles we can give permissions to
applications we can give permissions to
users in the same account in a different
account the corporate ID we can give
permissions to EC 2 s 3 RDS V PC and lot
more role is wide and I am user is is
not so wide you know it's very
constrained only for that I am user
let's talk about manage policies in AWS
manage policies there are two types you
know customer managed and Amazon managed
so manage policies are I am resources
there Express permissions using the I am
policy language now we can create
policies edit them manage them or manage
them separately from the I am user group
and roles which they are attached to to
say they are something that we can do to
managed policies if it is customer
managed and we can now update policy in
one place and the permissions
automatically extend to all the attached
entries so I can have like three
services for services point to a
particular policy and if I edit that
particular policy it's gonna reflect on
those three or four services so anything
that I allow it's gonna be allowed for
those four services anything that I
denied it's gonna be denied for the four
services imagine what would be without
the I am a managed policy will have to
go and specifically allow deny on those
different instances four or five times
depending on the number of instances
that we have so like I said there are
two types of managed policies one is
managed by us which is customer managed
policies and then
other is managed by AWS which is AWS
managed policy this question can you
give an example of an IM policy and a
policy summary this is actually to test
how well worst are you with the AWS
console the answer to your question is
look at the following policy this policy
is used to grant access to add update
and delete objects from a specific
folder now in this case name of the
folder is example folder and it's
present in a bucket called example
bucket so this is an I am policy on the
other hand the policy summary is a list
of access level resource and conditions
for each service defined in a policy so
I am policy is all about one particular
resource and the policy summary is all
about multiple resources with I am
policy it was only talking about s3
bucket and one particular s3 bucket here
it talks about CloudFormation template
cloud watch logs ec2 elastic Beanstalk
services summary summary of resources
and the permissions and policies
attached to them that's what policy
somebody is all about another question
could be like this what's the use case
of I am and how does I am help your
business to important or primary work of
I am is to help us manage iam users and
their access it provides secure access
to multiple users to their appropriate
AWS resources so that's one it does and
the second thing it does is manage
access for federated users federated
users or non iam users and through iam
we can actually allow and provide a
secure access to resources in our AWS
account to our employees without the I
am user know they could be authenticated
using the Active Directory they could be
authenticated using the Facebook
credential Google credential Amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials third-party Identity
Management right so we could actually
trust them and we could give them access
to our account based on the trust
relationship that we have built with the
other identity of systems it's two
things one is manage users and their
acts
for manage I am user and their access in
our AWS environment and second is
managed access for federated users who
are non I am users and more importantly
I am is a free service and with that
will only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the I am a username
and password that we create
all right let's now talk about some of
the questions in about 53 one classic
question that could be asked in an
interview is what is the difference
between latency based routing and geo
DNS or geo based a DNS routing now the
Geo based DNS routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of the geographic
location of the request and on the other
hand the latency based routing utilizes
latency measurements between networks
and data centers now latency based
routing is used where you want to give
your customers the lowest latency as
possible so that's when we would use
latency based routing and on the other
hand that geo based routing is when we
want to direct customers to different
web sites based on the country they are
browsing from you know you could have
you know two different or three
different web sites for the same URL you
know take Amazon the shopping website
for example when we go to amazon.com
from in the US it directs us to the US
web page where the products are
different and the currency is different
right and the flag and and a couple of
other advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from India it gets directed to the
amazon.com Indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the country
they're trying to browse if you want a
direct customers to two or three
different web sites we would use geo
based routing another use case of Geo
based routing is if we have a compliance
that you should handle all
the DNS requests sorry if you should
handle all the requests you know from a
country within the country then you
would do geo based routing you wouldn't
direct the customer to web server which
is in another country right you would
direct the customer to a server which is
very local to them that's another use
case of Geo based routing and like I
said for latency based routing the whole
goal or aim is to achieve minimum
end-user latency if you are hired for
the architect role and if that requires
working lot on the DNS then you could be
posted with this question what is the
difference between domain and a hosted
zone a domain is actually a collection
of data describing a self-contained
administrative and technical unit on the
Internet right so for example you know
simply learn comm is actually a domain
on the other hand hosted zone is
actually an container that holds
information about how you want to route
traffic on the Internet to a specific
domain for example LMS thought simpler
comm is an hosted zone whereas simply
learned comm is an eye domain so in
other words in hosted zone you would see
the domain name plus and a prefix to it
LMS is a prefix here FTP is a prefix
mail dot simply uncom as a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from route 53
would be how does Amazon tour 53 provide
high availability and low latency the
way Amazon around 53 provides high
availability and low latency is by
globally distributed DNS service Amazon
is a global service and they have DNS
services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an DNS server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the DNS providers there
are dns providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency a service
right it's always high latency it's low
latency for
local uses but anybody browsing from a
different country or a different
continent it's going to be high latency
for them but that's not again true with
Amazon Amazon is a globally distributed
DNS provider it has DNS servers global
white and like I said it has optimal
location it has got global servers or in
other words it has got servers around
the globe different parts in the globe
and that's how they are able to provide
high availability and because it's not
running on just one server but on many
servers they provide high availability
and low latency if the environment that
you're going to work on is going to take
a lot of configuration backups and we're
on mental backups then you can expect
questions in AWS config a classic
question would be how does AWS config
work along with AWS cloud trail a SS
clouds will actually records user API
activity on the account and you know any
HTTP HTTP access or any any sort of
access I know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any API calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in clouds rain it's
actually a logger it actually records
the activity in your cloud environment
on the other hand config is an point in
time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in AWS
config all right so with that
information you can always answer the
question what did my AWS resource
look like at a given point in time that
question gets answered when we use AWS
config on the other hand with cloud
trail you can answer the question I mean
by looking at the cloud trail or with
the help of cloud trail you can easily
answer the question who made an API call
to modify this resource that's answered
by cloud way and with the cloud trail we
can detect if security group was
incorrectly configured
who did that configuration let's say
that happened to be in downtime and you
wanna identify let's say there happen to
be a downtime and you want to identify
who made that change in the environment
you can simply look at cloud trail and
find out who made the change and if you
want to look at how the environment
looks like before the change you can
always look at AWS config I can't AWS
configure or a Robles config aggregate
data across different AWS accounts yes
it can now this question is actually to
test whether you have used AWS config or
not I know some of the services are very
local is that some of these services are
availability zone specifics some of them
are regional specific and some of them
are global a services in Amazon and
though some of the services our region
services you still can do some changes
you know add some configuration to it
and collect a regional data in it for
example s3 is a regional service but
still you can collect logs from all of
the regions into an s3 bucket in one
particular region that's possible and
cloud trailers and cloud watch is an
regional service but still you can with
some changes to it with some adding
permissions to it you can always monitor
the cloud watch that belongs to cloud
watch logs that belongs to other regions
you know they're not global by default
but you can do some changes and make it
global
similarly AWS config is a service that's
a region based service but still you can
make it act globally you can aggregate
data across a different region and
different accounts in an AWS config and
deliver the updates from different
accounts to one s3 bucket and can access
it from there aw config also works or
integrates seamlessly with SNS topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or a new edit that happened
in the environment let's look at some of
the data based questions you know
database should be running on reserved
instances so whether you know that fact
or not the interviewer wants to
understand how well you know that fact
by asking this question how
reserved instances different from on
demand our DB instances reserved
instances and on-demand instances are
exactly the same when it comes to their
function but they only differ based on
how they are built reserved instances
are purchased for one year or three year
reservation and in return we get a very
low per hour pricing because we're
paying upfront it's generally said that
resolved incidence is 75 percentage
cheaper than on-demand instance and
Amazon gives you that benefit because
you know you're committing for one year
and sometimes you're paying in advance
for the whole year on the other hand
there on the man instances are built on
an oddly Harley price talking about auto
scaling how will you understand the
different types of auto scaling the
interviewer might ask this question
which type of scaling would you
recommend for RDS and why the two types
of scaling as you would know now
vertical and horizontal and in vertical
scaling we can vertically scale up the
master database with a couple of clicks
all right so that's vertical scaling
vertical scaling is keeping the same
node and making it bigger and bigger if
previously it was running on Tito micro
now we would like to run it on M 3 2
times large instance previously it had
one virtual CPU one gigabit now it's
gonna have eight virtual CPU and 30
gigabit of RAM so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand the horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one VM now
it's gonna run on to 310 VMs that's
original our scaling so data base can
only be scaled vertically and there are
18 different types of instances we can
resize our RDS to all right so this is
true for our DS my sequel Postgres SQL
Maria DB Oracle Microsoft SQL servers
there are 18 type of instances we can
vertically scale up to on the other hand
horizontal scaling are good for a
replicas so they are read-only replicas
we're not going to touch the master
database we're not going to touch
the primary database but I can do
horizontal scaling only with Amazon
Aurora and I can add additional read
replicas I can add up to 15
read replicas for Amazon Aurora and up
to 5 read replicas for RDS my sequel
PostgreSQL and marie DB RDS instances
and when we add replicas we are
horizontally scaling adding more loads
right I read only notes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide that between vertical and
horizontal scaling if you're looking
into increase the storage and the
processing capacity we'll have to do a
vertical scaling if you're looking at
increasing the performance or of the
read heavy database we need to be
looking for horizontal scaling or we
need to be implementing horizontal
scaling in our environment still talking
about database this is another good
question you can expect in the interview
what is a maintenance window and Amazon
RDS will your DB instance be available
during the maintenance event all right
so this is really to test how well you
have understood the SLA how well you
have understood the Amazon RDS the
failure mechanism of Amazon RDS stuff
like that so Arya's maintenance window
it lets you decide when a DB instance
modification a database engine upgrades
or software patching has to occur and
you you actually get to decide should
happen at 12 in the night or should
happen at afternoon should it happen
early in the morning should happen in
the evening you actually get to decide
an automatic scheduling by Amazon is
done only for patches that are security
and durability related sometimes Amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and durability and by default the
maintenance window is is for 30 minutes
and the important point is the DB
instance will be available during that
event because you're gonna have primary
and secondary right so when that upgrade
happens Amazon would ship the connection
to the secondary do the upgrade and
they'll switch back to the primary
another classic question would be
what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in DynamoDB there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach consistency within a
second and sometimes when you write and
when you're you know trying to read
immediately chances that you would still
be reading the old data that's eventual
consistency on the other hand there is
another consistency model called the
strong consistency or strongly
consistent read where there is going to
be a delay in writing the data you know
making sure the data is written in all
places but it guarantees one thing that
is once you have done a write and then
you're trying to do a read it's gonna
make sure that it's going to show you
the updated data not the old data and
you can be guaranteed of it that it is
going to show the updated data and not
the old data that's strongly consistent
still talking about database talking
about no sequel DynamoDB or no sequel
database which is DynamoDB in amazon you
could be asked this question what kind
of query functionality does dynamodb
support dynamodb supports get and put
operation dynamodb supports or DynamoDB
provides a flexible querying by letting
you query on non primary key attributes
using global secondary index and local
secondary indexes a primary key can be
either a single attribute partition key
or a composite partition saut key in
other words a dynamo DB index is a
composite partition saut key as a
partition key element and a sort key
element and by holding the partition key
you know when doing a search or when
doing a query by holding the partition
key element constant we can search
across the sought key element to
retrieve the other items in that table
and in the composite partition a sort
key should be a combination of a user ID
partition and a timestamp so that's what
the composite partition sought key is
made of let's look at some of the
multiple choice questions you know
sometimes
deniz would have an a written test or an
MC q type online test before they call
you for at the first level or before
they call you for the second level
so these are some classical questions
that companies asked our companies ask
in their multiple-choice online
questions let's look at this question as
a developer using this paper use service
you can send store and receive messages
between software components which of the
following is being referred here let's
look at it right we have aw step
functions Amazon MQ Amazon simple queue
service Amazon simple notification
service let's see the question again as
a developer using this paper use service
so the service that we are looking for
is a paper or you service
you can send store and retrieve messages
between do software components kind of
like a queue there so what would be the
right answer it would be Amazon simple
queue service now Amazon simple queue
service is the one that's used to
decouple at the environment it breaks
the tight coupling and then it
introduces decoupling in that
environment by providing a queue or by
inserting a queue between two software
components let's look at this other
question if you would like to host a
real-time audio and video conferencing
application on a double yes it's an
audio and video conferencing application
on AWS this service provides you with a
secure and easy to use application what
is this service let's look at the
options they are Amazon chime Amazon
workspace Amazon MQ Amazon App Stream
alright you might tend to look at Amazon
app stream because it's real-time and a
video conference but it's actually for a
different purpose is actually Amazon
chime that lets you create chat and
create a chat board and then collaborate
with the security of the AWS services so
it lets you do the audio it's lets you
do the video conference all supported by
AWS security features it's actually
Amazon chime let's look at this question
as your company's aw solution architect
you are in charge of designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar
which of the following service best
serves your requirement
Arius ec2 auto-scaling Arab Lewis
snowball Arab loose forget NWS batch
let's read the question again as your
company's aw solution architect you are
in charge of designing thousands of
individual jobs which are similar it
looks like it's batch service let's look
at the other options as well aw snowball
is actually an storage transport service
easy to auto scaling is you know in
introducing scalability and elasticity
in the environment and AWS Fargate is
container services AWS batch is the one
is being referred here that actually
runs thousands of individual jobs which
are a similar kws batch it's a right
answer let's look at the other one you
are a machine learning engineer and
you're looking for a service that helps
you build and train machine learning
models in AWS which among the following
are we referring to so we have Amazon
sage maker and AWS deep lens Amazon
comprehend AWS device form let's read
the question again
you are a machine learning engineer and
you're looking for a service that helps
you build and train machine learning
models in AWS which among the following
are referred here the answer is sage
maker it provides every developer and
data scientists with the ability to
build train and deploy mission learning
models quickly that's what Sage Maker
does now for you to be familiar with you
know that the products I would recommend
are you to you know simply go through
the product description you know there's
one page available on Amazon that
explains all the products a quick neat
and simple
now that really helps you to be very
familiar with you know what the product
is all about then what it is capable of
you know is it the Divi service is it a
machine learning service or is it a
monitoring service is it a developer
service stuff like that so get that
information get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with a great conference so the
answer is Amazon sage maker because
that's the one that provides developers
and a data scientist the ability to
build a train and deploy machine
learning models quickly as possible
alright let's look at this one let's say
that you
working for your company's IT team and
you are designated to adjust the
capacity of the AWS resource based on
the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that actually helps us to adjust
the capacity of the AWS resource based
on the incoming application let's look
at it Amazon VCC Amazon I am Amazon
inspector Amazon elastic load balancing
Amazon BBC is a networking service
Amazon I am is an username password
authentication Amazon inspector is a
service that actually does security
audit in our environment and Amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly there helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balance and we can actually adjust the
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be Amazon elastic
load balancer alright let's look at this
question this cross-platform video game
development engine that supports PC Xbox
Playstation iOS and Android platforms
allows developers to build and host
their games on Amazon's servers so we
have Amazon game lyft Amazon green grass
Amazon a lumberyard Amazon Cimmerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports PC Xbox Playstation
iOS and Android platforms
allows developers to build and host
their games on Amazon servers the answer
is Amazon a lumberyard this lumberyard
is then free attribute a gaming engine
deeply integrated with AWS and twitch
with full source this lumberyard
provides a growing set of tools that
helps you create an highest game quality
applications and they connect to a lot
of games and vast compute and storage in
the cloud so it's that service they are
referring to let's look at this question
you are the project manager of your
company's cloud architect team you are
required to visualize understand and
you're a dubious cost and usage over
time which of the following service will
be the best fit for this we have a
double use budgets we have a Douglas
cost Explorer we have Amazon work mail
we have Amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost Explorer a cost
Explorer is an option in the Amazon
console that helps you to visualize and
understand and even manage the AWS cost
over time who's spending more who's
spending less and what is the trend what
is the projected cost for the coming
month all these can be visualized in AWS
cost Explorer let's look at this
question you are a chief cloud architect
at your company and how can you
automatically monitor and adjust
computer resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources so we have a cloud
formation as a service we have AWS
Aurora as a solution we have a double
use auto scaling and Amazon API gateway
let's read the question again
you're the chief cloud architect at your
company how can you automatically
monitor and adjust computer resources
how can you automatically monitor and
adjust computer resources to ensure
maximum performance and efficiency of
all scalable resources this is a easy
question to answer the answer is
auto-scaling
all right that's a basic service and
solution architect course is it auto
scaling is the service that helps us to
easily adjust monitor and ensure the
maximum performance and efficiency of
all scalable resources it does that by
automatically scaling the environment to
handle the inputs let's look at this
question as a database administrator you
will use a service that is used to set
up and manage databases such as my
sequel maya DB and Postgres SQL which
service are we referring to Amazon
Aurora Amazon ElastiCache AWS RDS AWS
database migration service Amazon Aurora
is Amazon's flavor of the RDS service
and elastic cache is is the caching
service provided by Amazon they are not
full-fledged
database and database migration service
just like the name says it helps to
migrate the database from on-premises to
the cloud and from one database flavor
to another day
with flavor Amazon RDS is the service is
the console is the service is the
umbrella service that helps us to set up
manage databases like my sequel Marie DB
and Postgres SQL it's Amazon RDS let's
look at this last question a part of
your marketing work requires you to push
messages to onto Google Facebook Windows
and Apple through api's or AWS
management console you will use the
following service so the options are AWS
cloud trail AWS config Amazon chime
arias simple notification service it
says a part of your marketing work
requires you to push messages it's
dealing with pushing messages to Google
Facebook Windows and Apple through api's
or AWS management console you will use
the following service it's simple
notification service simple notification
service is an message pushing a service
that sqs is pulling similarly SNS is
pushing right here it talks about a
pushing system that pushes messages the
Google Facebook windows and apple
through API and it's going to be a
simple notification system or a simple
notification service that's all I had a
40 interesting interview questions in
part 2 and I'm sure when you really
understand the background of the
question and how to answer the question
I'm sure you'll be able to crack the
interview and get the job that you've
been waiting for and we are very glad
that we were able to provide such
thoughtful questions and answers we were
able to collect design such thoughtful
and answer questions and provide it to
you so you can prepare well and move
forward in your career
it's samuel from simply lone thank you
again we'll meet you in another video as
soon as possible thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here